so Tracy can you tell us a little bit
about the crystal played parts project
yeah we're a group of mums dads and
grandparents that over the last 10 years
of fund raised and done grants and
events to raise money to build a play
park suitable for all ages and to keep
the youngsters off the streets leaving
fundraising now for about six years what
what impact have you had in that time
well in the last six years we I mean
basically we've gone from an old metal
slide to old wooden swings to now we
have got a complete junior area from
yoke right up to sort of 18 months to
sort of 14 15 year old and we've got our
basketball big flat basketball surface
with a rebound warfel playing football
on and we've just we're just in the
process now of completing a senior area
where it's got an assault course and a
zip wire and that's what the children
will is really asked for so Helen you've
created a play pot for all the children
here something that's not really very
common what was your motivation behind
this I think I'm living in a village
where you have obviously risa here
there's nothing for them really one with
him got a second preschool here
obviously what may be catered primary
but not for the secondary and I think
often people have a lot of input with
small children because they're you know
they go out and play with them things
out when it comes to old engine one they
don't want any adult input and they want
someone with a that's their own and
actually they can go somewhere and ok in
a safe environment but they don't have
the interference of other people and I
think we looked around and we decided
that they need somewhere so what we
started with with we are did a big
questionnaire and what came up is they
wanted a hard surface area where they
can skate and just kick a ball around or
play the basketball so that's what we
looked at then obviously that's why we
look for funding sources are very
expensive projects isn't a field to do
the drainage and everything else so I
just felt they needed something for them
because we only had quite an inadequate
junior play area and we thought well at
least they have something where's the
seniors had nothing at all part from
field
and what benefits do you think a good
play area brings to community well I
just think socialization for start I
think even though we've put this arian
for the seniors you get the juniors in a
small area you have the seniors here
they do cross over you know mums bring
toddlers along with ride ons and I think
it's more a sense of community not just
with the adults I think with children
they respect each other I think the old
ones helped us not being a little ones
and I think it's a it just brings
everybody together in a bit more than
sort of us and them and you know and
also being aware of other people that
are part of your community whether you
like it or not we have teenagers you
know we have toddlers and I think we
have to embrace everybody in the
community as a community